wer hierzulande kifft also Cannabis
konsumiert der macht die strafbar das
könnte sich mit der Ampelkoalition bald
ändern FDP und Grüne wollen Gras ähnlich
behandeln wie Gin kontrollierte Abgabe
ab 18 und der Staat verdient mit Vorbild
sind die Niederlande und Kanada durch
diese Entkriminalisierung würden Polizei
und Justiz entlastet ärzte warnen
dagegen vor einer Verharmlosung der
Droge Cannabis Legalisierung ihre weg
oder Ausweg darüber sprechen wir in
dieser phönix-runde
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend ganz herzlich
willkommen aus Berlin ich darf in meine
Gäste vorstellen bei uns ist Marie
agnesstag Zimmermann von der FDP seit
2017 im Bundestag Mitglied des
fdp-bundesvorstandes und zurzeit in
Koalitionsverhandlungen und ich begrüße
Andreas Müller er ist Jugend Richter am
Amtsgericht in Bernau bei Berlin und
zugeschaltet ist uns Dr Robin Hofmann er
ist Kriminologe an der Universität
Maastricht in den Niederlanden und
Professor Dr Maximilian gar er ist
Psychiater an der Universitätsklinik in
Ulm Frau Zimmermann sie sind in
Koalitionsverhandlungen sie sind aber
nicht in der Gruppe in der es um
Cannabis geht das sagen wir einfach mal
vorab weil es klar ist sonst würden sie
nämlich nicht hier sitzen weil in der
Tat weil ich da nicht vorgreifen möchte
das gebiete die Fairness insofern werden
das meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen
werden das Verhandeln genau aber klar
ist weil sie haben sich schon vorher
immer auch dazu geäußert dass sie
möchten das Cannabis legalisiert wird
bzw ist eine kontrollierte Abgabe da das
ist ein großer Unterschied
legalisieren nach dem Motto man kann es
kaufen ein Stück Schokolade und
konsumiertes oder lässt es bleiben
sondern wir wollen schon seit Jahren
eine kontrollierte Abgabe und vielleicht
einen Satz zuvor dass ich großen Respekt
und Verständnis dafür habe dass Menschen
auch Angst vor diesem Thema haben und
sagen meine Kinder Enkelkinder ich will
nicht dass die mit Substanzen in
Berührung kommen ich habe da Sorge vor
ich sage das nur vorneweg weil es eine
ernsthafte Diskussion ist aber in der
Tat die Freien Demokraten haben sich
eben für die kontrollierte Abgabe
ausgesprochen wir haben rund 3 Millionen
Menschen die regelmäßig Cannabis
konsumieren man redet von rund 12
Millionen Bundesbürgern die immer wieder
ab und zu konsumieren also das ist eine
große Zahl die werden alle durch die
Strafbarkeit kriminalisiert die Polizei
hält sich dran gerade bei jüngeren
Leuten das Ganze zu kontrollieren auch
zu ernten und weil sie das gerade im
Anfang gesagt haben nein die Niederlande
ist nicht das Vorbild für uns eben
gerade nicht weil in den Niederlanden
hat man in den 70er Jahren lediglich den
Verkauf angeregt hat nie kontrolliert
woher kommt das Gras wo wird es Angebot
gebaut wie sind die Vertriebswege genau
das wollen wir so nicht insofern
wollen wir diese kontrollierte Abgabe
aber für uns ist ganz elementar dass wir
schauen wo wird es angebaut welche
Qualität hat das Gras wie erreicht es
Deutschland und wie den Konsumenten und
das ganze umgesetzt werden soll genau
das gucken wir genau fragen wir gleich
nochmal aber nochmal die Frage warum
warum ist das so ein Thema wo sie sagen
dass das und da muss ich jetzt was
ändern nein ich glaube einfach dass wir
uns auch mal ehrlich machen müssen
dass diese Art von Prohibition die ist
mal in den 50er Jahren in den USA gab
eben auch die Situation so eröffnet hat
ich sagte gerade die Zahlen das
Millionen Menschen kriminalisiert werden
dass ein großer Schwarzmarkt herrscht
das gerade an junge Leute herangetreten
wird nach dem Motto willst du meine Tüte
keiner weiß was ist beigemischt das
Substanzen die man heute auch mit den
70er Jahren nicht mehr vergleichen kann
also das Gras der 70er dem ich begegnet
bin als junge Mädchen ist ein anderes
als heute
das heißt das gerade die Kontrolle und
ja ich sage das jetzt liberale die
staatliche Kontrolle dass die auch eine
Chance ist gesellschaftspolitisch ein
Thema ich sage mal ernsthaft aber auch
endlich mal abzuräumen was bei
konservativen anders gesehen wird aber
wir glauben die Zeit ist reif und
nochmal die Kriminalisierung von vor
allen Dingen jungen Leuten die ihr Jobs
ihre Jobs verlieren würden ist eben
einfach nicht mehr vertreten genau da
fragen wir doch mal direkt den
jugendtrichter Herr Müller wie oft
mussten mussten sie jemanden verurteilen
wegen Cannabis besitzt schon ich bin
jetzt 30 Jahre Richter ich habe
natürlich sich Verfahren gehabt wo
Cannabis Fälle drin vorkam nur seit etwa
zweieinhalb Jahren verurteiligt keine
Leute mehr wegen cann richtig geil in
welchen Mengen weil mehrere Verfahren
beim Bundesverfassungsgericht liegen sie
sind ausgesetzt worden vom Amtsgericht
Bernau vom Amtsgericht Münster und vom
Amtsgericht Pasewalk um zu prüfen ob
überhaupt die Cannabis
Prohibition verfassungsgemäß ist weil es
sind sehr viele Verstöße da
Gleichheitsgrundsatz Alkohol auf der
einen Seite Cannabis auf der anderen
Seite dann sind Verstöße gegen das
allgemeine handlungsrecht da
Freiheitsrechte man darf sich heutzutage
umbringen aber man darf nicht mal an der
Tüte ziehen ohne sich strafbar zu machen
und da liegt eine Vorlage deswegen bin
ich ganz froh dass ich seit zweieinhalb
Jahren alle Verfahren aussetze bis das
Bundesverfassungsgericht entschieden hat
und das habe ich gemacht
das habe ich gemacht und dann sieht man
da irgendwelche Menschen vor sich wo die
Eltern ohne weiteres erziehen können da
kommen in 17-Jährige die vielleicht mal
einen Gramm gehabt haben da kommen aber
auch Erwachsene an ich bin ja auch
zuständig für Erwachsene die sagen mir
Herr Müller sie wissen ich bin jemand
der eigentlich auf Alkohol gar nicht
zurechtkommt ich schlage und jetzt kiffe
ich ein bisschen das tut mir gut ja
jetzt werde ich aber verfolgt wegen der
cannabisgeschichte und dann frage ich
mich warum ist das so warum und jetzt
noch ein paar Zahlen dazu es sind 185
000 Ermittlungsverfahren bundesweit
jährlich da werden
Polizeibeamte dafür aufgefordert in die
Park zu gehen und so weiter wir haben
enorme Ressourcen Vergoldung diese
Verfahren ja wenn man diese ganze Kraft
der Polizei und der Justiz in wirkliche
kriminelle Geschichten packen würde dann
würde man eine ganze Menge schaffen noch
ein Wort zu beginnen ein Wort wir haben
in den vergangenen fünf Jahrzehnten
Hunderttausende von Menschen in die
Knäste geschickt wir haben Millionen von
Menschen mit Geldstrafen versehen oder
mit Geldbußen und wir haben gar nichts
erreicht wir haben keinen Jugendschutz
wir haben nichts erreicht das war die
falsche Politik sagen sie ich würde gern
zum Psychiater kommen zu Herrn was
befürchten sie dann wenn jetzt jetzt
haben wir die Argumente gehört beide die
gesagt haben es macht keinen Sinn dass
Leute kriminalisiert werden wir müssen
anders damit umgehen was befürchten sie
denn wenn es jetzt dazu kommt wie die
Ampelkoalition ist vor hat es sie sagen
ja es muss eine kontrollierte Abgabe
geben ist das dann eine höhere Akzeptanz
für Cannabis
also
zunächst denke ich kann man den
Argumenten der beiden vorräter in allen
Punkten zustimmen also auch wir
Psychiater und ich glaube auch die
meisten Ärzte sehen in der
Kriminalisierung des kann er benötigt
Gebrauchs keine
gesundheitspräventiven Effekte also das
hatte Müller ja sehr schön dargestellt
gerade ob wir verurteilen ob wir die
Leute in den Knast bringen das hat also
keinen präventiven Effekt aber jetzt um
zu Ihrer Frage zurückzukommen
es ist schlichtweg momentan unklar
welche Effekte eine Legalisierung und
eine auch kontrollierte Freigabe von
Cannabinoid Präparationen in Bezug auf
den Gesundheitsschutz in Deutschland
haben wird es ist allgemein bekannt dass
der Konsum von Cannabinoiden also ich
spreche bewusst von Cannabinoiden weil
wir nicht nur das Marihuana haben
sondern eben auch
synthetische cannabino dieser Konsum ist
mit Risiken verbunden also es gibt hier
allen voran des Risiko der
substanzgebrauchsstörungen also der
sogenannten Abhängigkeiten aber eben
auch vor allem bei den Jugendlichen
chronischen Konsumenten des Risiko für
anhaltende kognitive Beeinträchtigungen
also Verminderungen der geistigen
Leistungsfähigkeit einhergeht mit
schlechterer schulischer Performance mit
Verminderung der akademischen Leistungen
und so weiter wir haben aber auch das
Risiko für andere für die Entwicklung
anderer psychiatrische Erkrankungen wie
zum Beispiel im psychotische Störungen
dass es ein Störungsbild wo der
Zusammenhang mit dem Gebrauch von keiner
beliebten in der wissenschaftlichen
literaturkontrovers diskutiert wird aber
letztlich kann man schon davon ausgehen
dass der regelmäßige Gebrauch von keiner
benötigen zumindest das Risiko für die
Entwicklung einer psychotischen Störung
das sind schwerwiegende Störungen eben
erhöhen kann und jetzt machen wir es mal
konkret Herr gar einfach wenn ich sage
mal ein Jugendlicher der dreimal in der
Woche Joint raucht hat der ein höhere
ein höheres Risiko eine psychische
Erkrankung zu bekommen also wenn Sie das
so konkret fragen dann würde ich
pauschal sagen das ist richtig wir haben
mittlerweile sehr gute Daten auch
längsschnittdaten aus klinischen Studien
die zeigen dass der früh einsetzende
anhaltend also regelmäßige und
vielleicht auch hochdosierte Konsum aber
da ist eben die individuelle Varianz
also was ist sozusagen noch schädlich
was ist nicht schädlich eben sehr sehr
unterschiedlich und da haben wir sehr
sehr gute Daten die zeigen dass im
Konsumenten wo die Hirnreifung noch
nicht abgeschlossen sind eben diese
jungen Menschen diese angesprochen haben
ein hohes Risiko haben das kann im
Einzelfall eben nicht vorhanden sein
aber das weiß man eben nicht wenn man
regelmäßig konsumiert und man dann zu
der ein oder anderen Gruppe gehört ein
hohes Risiko für anhaltende kognitive
Beeinträchtigungen auch für chronische
irreversible hirnstrukturveränderungen
im übrigen das konnten auch Studien
zeigen eine große Studie die dieses Jahr
publiziert wurde und das finde ich ist
eben die besonders Minerale Gruppe an
die besonders gedacht werden sollte wenn
man jetzt hier in dieser mittlerweile
sehr aufgeheizten Debatte über eine
Legalisierung Freigabe spricht also wenn
man das sozusagen machen sollte also in
der Legalisierung eine Freigabe wie Frau
Schrack Zimmermann das gerade erläutert
hat dann ist es aus unserer Sicht sehr
sehr wichtig dass an Maßnahmen des
öffentlichen Gesundheitsschutzes zu
knüpfen zum Beispiel auch Prävention zum
Beispiel auch Aufklärung zum Beispiel
auch die Steuereinnahmen da kommen wir
gleich zu ich würde gerne in Hofmann
noch eben mit in die Diskussion nehmen
herr Hofmann sie Frau Zimmermann hat
schon gesagt die Niederlande sind für
sie kein Vorbild aber in dem Sinne ist
es ja deshalb habe ich es auch genannt
am Anfang so das Vorbild nach dem Motto
wir gefahren die Niederlande und da kann
man dann einfach das das Gras kaufen das
ist das was viele Jugendliche einfach
tun herr Hofmann und eben viele Deutsche
die dort als Touristen hinfahren die
brauchen da nicht hinfahren die können
hier um der Ecke gehen in den nächsten
Park und holen sich irgendeinen Scheiß
das Land ist wo ich hinfahren kann und
mir Drogen kaufen herr Hofmann so ist
das so ist das Bild ich glaube viele aus
NRW tun das auch weil es weil sie da an
der Grenze sind herr Hofmann ist
inwieweit sind die Niederlande ein
überhaupt noch eine Vorbild wenn man
hier darüber redet dass man etwas ändern
möchte
ja also die Niederlande sind was die
cannabis-levelisierung angeht eigentlich
kein Vorbild man hat in Niederlanden das
wurde je mehr schon angesprochen
eigentlich zwei Fehler gemacht
damals als es legalisiert wurde also
etwa in den 70er Jahren das erschienen
opportun so im Rahmen der
Hippie-Bewegung in einem liberalen Land
den Verkauf von Cannabis zu legalisieren
was man versäumt hat war dass man auch
den Einkauf auf Seiten der
Coffeeshops Legalisierung legalisiert
hat das wird heute unter dem unter dem
Konzept der Hintertür Problematik
diskutiert soll heißen nach vorne raus
ging es legal hinten rein kam das
Cannabis aber nur illegal und in diese
Lücke haben sich dann über die Jahre
Drogenbanden festgesetzt die das
Cannabis aus Marokko und Türkei hier
angeliefert haben und dann wurde es
relativ schnell zu einem Big Business
das muss man so sagen und
da hat man dann den zweiten großen
Fehler eigentlich gemacht und das war
als dann diese Banden auf das viel
profitablere Kokain umgestiegen sind das
war so etwa eine 90er Jahren da hat man
weggeschaut da hat man also nicht die
Warnzeichen erkannt und da hat sich
eigentlich die Situationen entwickelt
mit Kokain wie sie heute ist und heute
haben wir in den Niederlanden ein
offenen drogenkonflikt wir haben
Liquidationen auch auf einer Straße 20
bis 30 pro Jahr wir haben einen offenen
gewaltkonflikt auf der Straße und da
heißt es natürlich wenn man über
Legalisierung in Deutschland diskutiert
dass man diese Fehler nicht wiederholt
inwieweit oder kommen wir dann mal dazu
wie würden sie es denn umsetzen wenn die
Niederlande kein Vorbild sind also wenn
machen wir es auch konkret wenn ich ein
Geschäft habe oder
wo ich die Drogen kaufen kann wie kommen
die Drogen ins Geschäft also sie
sprechen von Drogen ich spreche jetzt
noch mal bewusst von Cannabis damit hier
nicht der Eindruck erweckt wird dass wir
hier von synthetischen oder heroinen
oder irgendwelchen harten Stoffregen wir
reden also von der Drohne kann man auch
wenn Sie so wollen ja wir reden ja jetzt
nicht über Alkohol ich glaube die
Hektoliter die da täglich über die Theke
gehen ich lass es mal außen vor weil um
uns auf das Thema zu konzentrieren in
der Tat die Niederlanden waren in den
70er Jahren ich komme aus Düsseldorf aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen war das das Thema da
fährt man mal hin und kifft meine Runde
das mit heute zu vergleichen wäre ein
Fehler und das Image ist auch nicht mehr
so ich habe drei Kinder und meine beiden
Söhne haben in den Niederlanden studiert
und immer wenn die nach Düsseldorf kam
mit dem Zug wurden die im Zug nach links
gedreht weil man eben nicht wollte
das sozusagen das Zeug nach Deutschland
kommt in der Tat hier in Berlin brauchen
wir hier nur um die Ecke zu gehen
also was ganz entscheidend ist und ich
sage das bewusst als freie Demokratin
und lieberale eine solche Sache muss
staatlich kontrolliert werden also wir
haben momentan in Deutschland drei
Firmen nach aus nach Ausschreibung zwei
kanadische die in Deutschland Cannabis
anbauen also Hanf anbauen und ein
Startup Unternehmen aus Berlin die sind
jetzt aufgefordert und machen es auch
schon in unter anderem in Neumünster
gibt noch zwei andere Städte wo Hanf
angebaut wird das heißt zum ersten Mal
wird etwas in Deutschland produziert und
zwar unter strengsten Auflagen nicht nur
die dieses eigentliche
der eigentliche Anbau der gerade zu
unter hochsicherheit geschieht damit
eben die Substanz sauber ist damit sie
kontrollierbar ist damit Sie wenn Sie
oder jemand anders ein Joint raucht weiß
was was raucht er da gerade das ist das
eine dann der Weg in die lizenzierte
Abgabe das kann eine Apotheke sein das
kann ein spezielles Geschäft sein aber
es muss lizenziert sein und das heißt
dass es bis zum Verkauf an Erwachsene an
frühestens ab 18-Jährige über das Alter
kann man immer diskutieren aber wie
gesagt jetzt mal ab 18 dann auch
entsprechend verkauft wird dieser ganze
weg muss hart kontrolliert und auch
besteuert werden das ist dann aber doch
wer kontrolliert ist das ist eine
staatliche Kontrolle
für die Polizei die Polizei hat sich
auch in der Gegend
ein paar Sachen will ich noch sagen weil
muss ja auch mal was sagen bin ja auch
ein bisschen Fachmann so erstens die
Niederlande hat zumindestens eins
geschafft sie hat über 50 Jahre keine
Konsumenten verfolgt und die
konsumentenverfolgung die muss hier
sofort aufhören möglichst in den
nächsten 100 Tagen es kann nicht angehen
das ganz normale Menschen verfolgt
werden weil sie lediglich Cannabis zu
sich nehmen abends mit ihrer Frau was
rauchen und das hat die Niederlande
gemacht dann hat und man nennt das ganze
Duldungspolitik ja man hat vergessen das
wurde ja schon erzählt ja wie kommt es
rein und deswegen erwarte ich hier eine
vernünftige Umsetzung und hier noch was
zu hören Professor Gore ist glaube ich
richtig natürlich hat ein übermäßiger
Konsum von Cannabis bei jungen Menschen
folgen das habe ich auch in den letzten
30 Jahren gesehen aber man weiß zum
Beispiel überhaupt nicht und dann muss
ich ihn leicht widersprechen ja ob eine
Psychose aufgrund des Cannabiskonsums
entsteht oder aber weil die Leute die
jungen Leute bereits vorher psychische
Probleme hatten das ist bis heute
wissenschaftlich nicht geklärt aber es
wird immer Angst gemacht damit und dann
muss man auch was dazu
zu diesem wichtigen Punkt lassen Sie mal
kurz ein Garnison genau
recht also die Frage nach der Kausalität
zwischen Cannabinoid Konsum und
Entwicklung Aufrechterhaltung
psychotische Störung das wird in der
wissenschaftlichen literaturkontrovers
diskutiert haben sie vorkommen recht da
kann man eine letztlich die oder die
Meinung vertreten und man kann für die
oder die Meinung sich eben die oder die
Literatur raussuchen also da muss ich
Ihnen Recht geben aber wir haben ja
nicht nur das Risiko der Entwicklung von
das fragliche Risiko von psychotischen
Störungen sondern eben auch das Risiko
von Abhängigkeitserkrankungen das Risiko
für irreversible hirnstrukturelle
Hirnveränderungen kognitive
Beeinträchtigungen und vermutlich auch
Angststörungen und depressive Stimmung
das ist eben Leute haben relativ klar
also das möchte ich kurz noch das möchte
ich bitte noch abschließen weil mir das
wirklich an Anliegen ist das ist
indiskutabel dafür gibt es Evidenz diese
Bevölkerungs Gruppe also die jungen
Menschen die früh chronisch konsumieren
sind besonders gefährdet und da muss von
der Politik auch ein entsprechender
Schutz erfolgen sonst glaube ich dass
das eben für die Gesundheit ein großes
Risiko völlig recht wie sie mir auch
recht geben ich wollte nur sagen ich
also ich will ihnen nicht widersprechen
weil das ist Fakta also die Anzahl das
kann ich nicht sagen ich bin keine
Medizinerin das natürlich jeder
Missbrauch das ist ja immer die Frage
des Maßes wie immer im Leben das haben
sie beim Alkohol auch das berühmte Glas
Rotwein am Abend ist was anderes als
wenn man die Flasche morgens schon
ansetzt aber
entscheidend ist natürlich wie gesagt
wie wir damit umgehen und das ist eben
einer einer Kontrolle Bedarf und
deswegen ist es wirklich spannend über
die Niederlande zu sprechen weil ganz
tolle habe für die für ab 18 jetzt sagen
aber ich habe so einen Geschäft oder
eine Apotheke wenn ich 18 bin kriege ich
dann kann ich das ist wie das ist wie
sie wollen eine Flasche Schnaps genau
wir wissen aber auch genau das auch 16
und 15-jährige Schnaps trinken
aber dann ist doch die Frage müssen wir
müssten wir müssen wieder zurück zu
unserem Professor ja wir haben doch auf
dem Markt Sachen die sind nicht gut für
Jugendliche sind ethische Drogen die
machen die Köpfe kaputt und die jungen
Leute gehen sowieso trotz der Provision
und kriegen es an jeder Ecke und was wir
brauchen und da gebe ich Ihnen nicht bis
ich bin heute ganz froh ja ich gebe
Ihnen Recht sie geben mir recht und wir
sind auf einer Linie was wir brauchen
ist ein vernünftiger Jugendschutz in
diesen Jugendschutz haben wir nicht in
Deutschland sterben an legal heißt
jährlich junge Leute oder landen in den
Kliniken weil sie sich sogenannte
Ersatzdrogen besorgen
Soße aussehen wird wir können eine
vernünftige Prävention machen wir können
vernünftig mit den Menschen reden die
Eltern können offen und ehrlich die
Problematik die ihrer Kinder beurteilen
ohne die Angst zu haben dass der Polizei
mal nebenan steht oder die Nachbarin
Anzeige erstattet all diese Geschichten
sind Jugendschutz und diesen
Jugendschutz haben wir nicht und dann
würden und dann bin ich fest und
überzeugt immer noch einige Leute in die
Kliniken gehen aber da gehen sie trotz
der gegenwärtigen Situation hin aber
Millionen von Menschen mit kämen ihre
Freiheit zurück ich würde trotzdem gerne
mal wieder Herr hofern was denken Sie
was sich ändern würde wenn jetzt in
Deutschland das kontrolliert freigegeben
wird was würde sich zum Beispiel auf
unseren Schulhöfen ändern
nichts ja also
ganz klar sagen und da gebe ich auch
Herr Müller recht Prävention
ist da wirklich das wichtigste man muss
das auf dem Schirm behalten man muss
ganz genau hinschauen das ist das zweite
was wir eigentlich von den Niederlanden
lernen können also erstens nicht die
gleichen Fehler machen und zweitens
diesen normalisierungseffekt der wird
hier heißt diskutiert also sprich hat
eigentlich die Legalisierung des
Cannabis dazu geführt dass
andere Drogen konsumiert werden also
wenn man die synthetischen Drogen wurden
bereits angesprochen der Schritt vom
Cannabis zum zur synthetischer Droge ist
nicht mehr so wahnsinnig weit und dann
zum kokain ist auch nicht mehr so weit
und da das wird kontrovers diskutiert
aber da muss man das ist das wichtigste
und das ist auch mir ganz wichtiges
Anliegen dass man da genau hinschaut das
heißt einerseits sich anschaut wie die
Konsumenten reagieren das heißt sehen
wir wirklich mit der Digitalisierung
dass die Kids gerade Jugendliche auf
härtere Drogen zugreifen und das zweite
was passiert auf der Dealer Seite also
sprich die die
Nachfrage heute nach Cannabis bedienen
die Dealer die großen Drogen Netzwerke
die wir auch in Deutschland haben
satteln die massiv auf härtere Drogen um
überschwemmen in den Markt mit harten
Drogen mit Kokain mit den mit Ecstasy
das sind die wirklich die wirklich
gefährlichen Drogen und da muss man ganz
genau hinschauen da muss man das
wirklich und darauf achten dass dieser
Effekt dass man die von vornherein
ausschließen kann
wie wird man das schaffen sie wollen ja
auch dass es eine Steuer geben soll auf
Cannabis das heißt das Produkt wird
erstmal teurer und wenn man jetzt das
spricht für die Qualität erstmal hat man
dann ist es teurer aber man weiß dass
was man konsumiert hat eine andere
Qualität als wenn sie es an der Ecke
bekommen wo man nicht weiß was beiget
wurde das ist das ist das eine ja das
muss versteuert werden und ja ein
bisschen mehr wert man spricht davon 1,2
bis 1,3 Milliarden das ein Teil davon in
die Prävention geht und Prävention nicht
nur was Cannabiskonsum betrifft sondern
was gerade gesagt wurde was deutlich
härtere Drogen betrifft was man dann so
in Discos und Clubs angeboten bekommt
bis hin in die Prävention von Alkohol
weil das Problem was sie natürlich bei
jungen Menschen haben ist ja nicht nur
das ausprobieren sondern was wird Ihnen
zu Hause vorgelebt und wenn die Eltern
Familie ihren Wein pichelt und das
Schnäppchen in den Bier ins Bier und im
Jahr im Oktoberfest wird wird Bier
reingeschüttet ich weiß gar nicht wie
die Leute das lassen
dann ist das ja auch das ist lustig und
das ist nett und das gehört dazu aber
viele Jugendliche trinken ja und deshalb
wäre schon noch meine Frage aber die
Prävention weil Alkohol so
gesellschaftlich ganz normal akzeptiert
besserer Fachmann es sind wenn ich darf
eben meine Frage stellen wenn
Jugendliche trinken viel weil Alkohol so
gesellschaftlich akzeptiert ist und sie
ist gut weil es schnell verschwunden ist
dieser Welt ich frage jetzt wenn
Marihuana ähnlich gesellschaftlich
akzeptiert ist wie Alkohol ist da nicht
die Gefahr dass noch viel mehr
Jugendliche am Anfang wird wird es so
sein dass vielleicht sie auch in den
nächsten Coffeeshop gehen und erstmal
eine Tüte probieren dann gefällt Ihnen
das nicht und sagen wir ich trinke
lieber wieder meinen Rotwein garantiert
wird am Anfang mehr gekifft werden weil
alle probieren es mal aus dann wird sich
das normalisieren und die Länder die wir
hier im Auge haben haben ja schon
gezeigt dass zum Beispiel die
Niederlande der kiffen nicht mehr
Menschen und unter 18 Jahren als in
Deutschland hier kiffen viel viel mehr
also es ist nicht so der
Wissenschaftliche Dienst des Bundestages
hat schon festgestellt dass es wieder
auf völlig normale Ebene gelangt noch
ein Wort zu obwohl ich sie ja so mag ja
dürfen sie trotzdem
2,66
Milliarden werden eingesperrt jährlich
hinzu kommen die Einsparung bei Polizei
da bin ich ja Justiz also deswegen die
Zahlen ich habe dir alle im Kopf
Milliarden die man alleine aus steuern
generiert ja ihr Chef von der FDP
Finanzminister wird dann soll er jetzt
schon mal sagen da sind etwa 4
Milliarden die wir reinholen können da
können wir mit Häuser und Wohnungen
bauen okay also kiffen für den
Wohnungsbau Wohnungsbau auch da brauchen
Sie natürlich
die haben nämlich den Nachteil weil sie
zugeschaltet sind und nicht hier am
Tisch sitzen deshalb ist
wenn sie jetzt jetzt noch mal diese
Frage wenn sich jetzt Eltern also Eltern
die junge Kinder haben der Jugendliche
oder deren die merken ihre Kinder
Rauchen hat Marihuana und jetzt hören
Sie diese Diskussion über die Freigabe
die machen sich Sorgen die denken oh
Gott das wird jetzt alles schlimmer was
sagen sie solchen Eltern
also ich würde diesen Eltern sagen dass
sich vermutlich für die Kinder durch die
vermutlich sorgfältigen Veränderungen
des gesetzlichen Rahmens in Bezug auf
den kanaritgebrauch nichts ändern wird
und deswegen um noch mal kurz auf Herrn
Müller zu sprechen zu kommen Prävention
und Kriminalisierung hat er nichts
miteinander zu tun also man kann
natürlich jetzt auch schon
wunderbar präventiv wirksam sein auch
ganz unabhängig von einer
Kriminalisierung oder nicht aber ich
würde den Eltern sagen dass das jetzt
zunächst mal ein Problem ist dass mit
dem gesetzlichen Rahmen nichts zu tun
hat und man trotzdem natürlich sehr
genau das Konsumverhalten der Kinder
beobachten soll
offen damit umgehen soll das ganze nicht
verteufeln die man dämonisieren aber
natürlich schon sehr aufmerksam die
Effekte und den Umgang des Kindes und
die Haltung des Kindes in Bezug auf den
Gebrauch beobachten sollte ich würde
gerne noch zwei Punkte kommentieren zu
dieser sehr regen und
leidenschaftlichen Diskussion von Frau
stark Zimmermann und Herrn Müller im
Vorfeld und zwar zwei Punkte möchte ich
gerne kommentieren und zwar der erste
Punkt ist die Kontrolle also das ist ja
etwas was immer wieder als Argument für
die Freigabe herangeführt aber die Frage
ist doch was will man denn überhaupt
kontrollieren also es ist so ich habe
vorher schon gesagt keiner binoide das
ist ein Stoffgemisch da gibt diese
synthetischen cannabidien die werden
sicherlich nicht in diesem Coffeeshop
sind in Apotheken verkauft in
Deutschland das ist völlig klar sie wir
sprechen über Marihuana also über das
Gras und Gras das wissen Sie ja auch
vermutlich das ist eine Mischung aus 500
Substanzen die bekanntesten Sound das
cannabidionen das THC das kann er Video
gilt ja als das möglicherweise arzneilig
wirksame
Ingredienz das nicht so toxisch ist und
das THC das tetrahydrocannabidio
Cannabinol gilt als die Substanz die
eben
psychotoxische Effekte haben kann und in
der Debatte hört man immer wieder man
kann dann eben Züchtungen generieren und
dann kontrolliert produzieren ein Gras
das eben nicht toxisch ist und das ist
natürlich Quatsch das hat sich
impliziert schon gezeigt die Dosis macht
das Gift und selbst wenn man dann in den
Apotheken den die Freigabe ab 21 und das
möchte ich auch noch an der Stelle sagen
ein 21-jähriger Mann bei dem ist
gehirnreifen noch nicht abgeschlossen
also bei der kann durchaus noch toxische
kumulative Effekte erwerben die
regelmäßigen Gebrauch also ab wann wenn
ab wann wäre würde man sagen hat es
keinen großen Schaden mehr die
neurobiologische Forschung die wir jetzt
haben die würde sagen frühestens ab 21
das ist ja so ein so eine Zahl auf die
man sich einigen könnte vermutlich
besser wäre wahrscheinlich 25 aber da
würde Herr Müller wahrscheinlich wild
werden und
bei der Kontrolle wird das werden wir
noch wichtig dass Sie das abschließen
kann bei der Kontrolle wie gesagt
zunächst mal die Frage also die Hoffnung
dass man mit einer Kontrolle der der
disquotienten also diese Ausgewogenheit
zwischen Tee hat sie und keine bidiol
die die Toxizität also die Giftigkeit
der Substanz wirklich in Griff kriegt
das ist eigentlich unbegründet denn die
Dosis macht das Gift und die häufig des
kaltes Konsums und so weiter das ist der
eine Punkt und dann die andere ist
natürlich es wird auch immer wieder
gesagt man kann dann kontrollieren wer
das eben bekommt also das geht dann vor
allem über das Alter das ist völlig klar
natürlich werden dann trotzdem jüngere
illegal konsumieren das ist völlig klar
das klammere ich jetzt mal aus aber
ein anderer Punkt in dieser ganzen
Diskussion ist jetzt bisher noch nicht
zur Sprache gekommen und da wird
wahrscheinlich auch der Puls von Herrn
Müller gleich noch mal richtig hochgehen
das ist nämlich die Frage ob eben die
Legalisierung eine Signalwirkung eine
sozusagen einen Aufforderungscharakter
haben kann also die DGP werden also
meine Fachgesellschaft hatte schon
gesagt und auch die die deutsche
Ärzteschaft dass man auf keinen Fall
Werbung erlauben sollte also
werbungsverbot das hat der völlig
offensichtlichen Konsum
Aufforderungscharakter aber wie ist es
denn jetzt tatsächlich was erwartet sich
die Gesellschaft die Politik von im
Effekten der Legalisierung auf die
Haltung der Konsumenten in Bezug auf den
Konsum ich möchte Ihnen Beispiel geben
aus meinem täglichen Arbeit ein Beispiel
aus meiner Freiheit ein vier bis acht
oder zwölf Millionen Menschen erstmal
lernen und wir müssen mal Zahlen nennen
trotzdem alle überlegen wie viel noch
mit meinen Ausführungen
im psychosomatischen Anstalten das hört
sich alles an als ob ein die ganzen
Kliniken in der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland mit Cannabiskonsumenten voll
sind das ist nicht der Fall aber so wird
das immer es wird eine nein überhaupt
nicht gesagt haben sie mich falsch
verstanden
dann aber vorstellen genau es gab nur
noch einen Punkt also sie alle wissen
2017 gab es eben die medizinal Hanf
Gesetzgebung in Deutschland und seitdem
ist es möglich
Marihuana zu Lasten der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung an Patienten zu
verorten die schwer krank sind bei denen
die üblicherweise angewendeten
Therapieverfahren nicht angewendet
werden können weil sie nicht wirksam
sind und so weiter und so fort und wo
eben durch Cannabis in Aussicht auf
Erfolg besteht das wissen sie alle und
das hat aus meiner persönlichen
klinischen Arbeit heraus es gibt dazu
keine Daten das ist noch nicht
untersucht worden schon dazu geführt
dass bei den Patienten eine Veränderung
der Haltung gegenüber Marihuana der
früheren Droge entstanden ist und die
Patienten letztlich die Haltung
entwickelt haben es ist ein Medikament
also das ist eine
fundamentale Veränderung der subjektiven
Bewertung diese Substanz und wenn jetzt
der Staat das legalisiert und Klammer
auf es gibt Daten aus den USA die zeigen
sehr wohl dass in gewissen
Bevölkerungsschichten in den fünf Jahren
nach der Legalisierung der Konsum gerade
in den vulnerablen Bevölkerungsgruppen
massiv angestiegen ist okay
welches Signal geht aus davon von dieser
Freigabe und wenn der Arzt wenn die die
Ärzteschaft also auf dem deutschen
Ärztetag die haben jetzt noch mal ganz
klar gesagt sie finden es nicht gut sie
warnen vor dieser sie haben aber auch
gesagt und das musste auch der zweite
Punkt sein dass man es zumindest als
Ordnungswidrigkeit herunterstufen soll
man sagt immer nur die waren völlig klar
aber nicht den zweiten Bundes habe ich
heute tausend meiner Presse
gegangenisierung verharmlost auch die
gesundheitlichen Gefahren negativen
Folgen und langzeiten
was ist das Signal was davon ausgeht das
erste Signal ist dass wir uns in diesem
Land mal ehrlich machen es gibt Länder
da kann man Cannabis konsumieren und hat
Alkoholverbot es ist also eine
gesellschaftliche Sicht der Sache ich
will die Gefahren die gerade aufgeführt
sind überhaupt nicht verniedlichen es
wird letztendlich die Aufgabe sein der
Eltern der Erzieher Lehrerinnen und
Lehrer das zum thematisieren aber es ist
auch ein Appell an die
Eigenverantwortung von jungen Menschen
dass sie verantwortlich sind für ihr
Leben aber die Aufklärung brauchen damit
Sie wissen dass es eben kein Keks ist in
den sie beißen sondern dass sie etwas
konsumieren was bei größerer wenn wenn
man es zu oft zu viel macht eben auch zu
Schäden führen kann und ich glaube diese
Diskussion in Deutschland und darum geht
es uns auch dieses Eigenverantwortung
diese jungen Menschen aufzuklären sie
werden nie verhindern können dass ein
16-Jähriger zum 18-Jährigen sagt oder
zum 21-Jährigen bringen wir das mal mit
da wir brauchen nicht naiv zu sein aber
es zu thematisieren nicht
kriminalisieren darüber offen zu
sprechen sehr früh wie wir ja auch
übrigens bei den Gefahren im Netz im
Internet wo man heute sehr früh an
Kinder und Jugendliche geht um ihn
gefahren klar zu machen die ist überall
gibt und ich glaube dass wir auch ein
Menschenbild haben müssen nicht davon
auszugehen dass es das ist 20 30 40
Millionen Menschen gibt die nicht wissen
was sie tun sondern die
gesellschaftliche Aufgabe ist es ohne
mich wiederholen zu wollen kontrollieren
so weit es geht ist in den Verkauf zu
bringen mit den nötigen Begrenzungen es
entsprechend teuer zu machen um mit dem
Mehrwert eben in die Prävention zu gehen
ich glaube schon ist es auch wenn es
teuer ist dass dann vielleicht ja
jüngere Leute doch dann eher auf den
Dialog aber lassen Sie mich nur noch
Einsatz sagen weil ich glaube dass das
Thema Eigenverantwortung selbstbewusst
groß zu werden mit Gefahren groß zu
werden dass man Kindern Jugendlichen
viel beibringen kann dass wir auch
Vertrauen haben müssen dass wenn wir das
richtig aufsetzen da auch eine Chance
haben da darum geht es und ich habe da
keine Angst vor wenngleich ich die
Diskussion ja auch mit meinen Kindern
hatten und ich habe Enkelkinder
inzwischen möchte ich auch nicht dass
die sich wenn sie älter werden ständig
sowas reinpfeifen aber die Augen davor
zuzumachen halte ich für ein ganz ganz
großen Fehler allein die Debatte heute
finde ich sehr gelungen dass man es mal
abschichtet was wäre was könnte sein und
dass wir eben nicht auf die Niederlande
realisieren ich möchte noch ein Wort
hier verlieren Einsatz vielleicht so
medizinal Cannabis eingeführt 2017 im
Moment haben in Deutschland
schätzungsweise 50 bis 100.000 Leute ein
Rezept die Leute die
Leute die privat zahlen ja kriegen das
schneller weil die Ärzte ja kein große
keinen großen Aufwand haben es gibt aber
unheimlich viele Patienten Menschen die
krank sind die würden gerne Cannabis
bekommen und bekommen es nicht und das
ist auch eine Folge der Prohibition und
wir müssen noch Bedenken im Moment im
Moment zahlen die Krankenkassen
wahnsinnig viel für medizinal Cannabis
warum sollen nicht Leute vernünftige
Leute die alt sind krank sind oder sonst
was zu Hause das Recht bekommen sich
drei Hanfpflanzen wir reden von Hanf das
stand immer auf den Boden dann ist ja
die Frage dann können sie könnten sie ja
damit auch handeln nein mein Wein kann
ich auch handeln wenn ich den Einfuhr
einführe aus irgendeinem Land und sage
ist toller Wein verkaufe ich dir das
sind ordentliche Menschen wir bestrafen
durch die Prohibition ordentliche
Menschen die Steuern zahlen ja die jeden
Tag arbeiten gehen und so weiter und wir
bestrafen kranke Menschen und das sollte
aufhören und wir müssen zeitgleich den
Schutz der Jugend erhöhen der ist
zurzeit nicht da und ich wüsste nicht
was aber konsequent auch konsequent
natürlich man muss sofort und ich
appelliere an die zukünftige Koalition
stoppen Sie die tagtägliche Verfolgung
von Millionen Menschen sofort in den
nächsten 100 Jahren 100 Tagen und machen
Sie die Patienten frei ich kriege jeden
Tag sie wissen ja 100.000 von Volleyball
Nachrichten wo Leute die als Patient ja
normalerweise Cannabis kriegen können es
nicht kriegen aber dann von der Polizei
verfolgt werden das ist da wie wird es
eigentlich konkret umgesetzt ist eine
Bundessache dann müssen die Länder des
Einzelnen das ist eine Bundessache aber
ich will auch nicht vorgreifen wir
werden konstruktiv in diese Gespräche
gehen und unsere Meinung ist klar und
die der anderen auch und ich bin
zumindest optimistisch dass wir in
dieser Farbkonstellation politischen
farbkonstellationen in dieses Thema mit
aller Ernsthaftigkeit so wie wir es auch
jetzt sagen dass wir da eine Lösung
finden herr Hofmann was gibt es in den
Niederlanden jetzt Diskussionen zu
verändern weil man gerade das Problem
hat mit der organisierten Kriminalität
schaut man dann auch auf Deutschland und
auch wie darüber jetzt hier diskutiert
wird oder zum Beispiel wie Kanada es
umsetzt also versucht man da vielleicht
auch noch mal neue Wege zu gehen
nach Deutschland schaut man schon mit
großem Interesse was diese Legalisierung
debatter angeht allerdings jetzt ändern
an der bestehenden Lage wird eigentlich
wird nicht diskutiert das ist ein Stück
weit die Coffeeshops ein Stück weit von
chlore hier und gehört zur Kultur
irgendwie mit dazu also dass man jetzt
darüber ernsthaft diskutieren würde
diese abzuschaffen oder ist wieder zu
illegalisieren das ist keine Debatte
hier worüber man diskutiert dass es
tatsächlich eben die organisierte
Kriminalität worüber man diskutiert ist
über die harten Drogen wie kann man da
diese Probleme eigentlich lösen wie kann
man da gegen vorgehen und das ist eine
Debatte die seit einigen Jahren ins
Rollen gekommen ist das eine sehr
wichtige Debatte ich würde mir manchmal
wünschen dass in Deutschland da auch
vielleicht etwas verstärkt über die
harten Drogen eigentlich diskutiert wird
über Kokain warum ist Kokain eine
Lifestyle Droge geworden in den letzten
Jahren warum haben wir so viel Kokain
Konsumenten
also da drehen sich die Debatten
eigentlich hier in den Niederlanden
drumherum da ist man ein Stück weiter
kann man eigentlich sagen okay das wäre
auch noch mal die die Frage weil das ist
Frau straktsam und das was schon viele
befürchten dass sie sagen wenn wir jetzt
anfangen das so umzusetzen wenn wir
sagen Marihuana
es wird dann legalisiert
entkriminalisiert dann kommt bald
vielleicht die Frage nach anderen Drogen
ja aber umso wichtiger ist es ja dass
wir diese Diskussion führen und auch
konsequent handeln es hat ja überhaupt
keinen Sinn und da haben sie ja völlig
recht Herr Müller wir haben einen
Jugendschutz der nicht richtig greift
weil er nicht richtig weil es auch viel
ist weil es auch anstrengend ist weil
die Polizei anderer Aufgaben hat den
konsequent durchzusetzen und natürlich
wenn in einem Club bestimmte Drogen
gehandelt werden dann muss die Hütte ich
bin keine Juristin ich sage das jetzt
mal so salopp dann muss diese Hütte
dicht gemacht werden und da darf auch
nicht weggekommen werden aber auch nicht
Realität realistisch doch das ist
realistisch schauen Sie sie können wenn
sie wenn sie grenzen stecken dann kann
ich immer nur empfehlen das macht man
auch bei Kindererziehung und
grundsätzlich wenn sie grenzen ziehen
müssen diese auch kontrollierbar sein
und sie müssen auch Folgen haben aber
dann sollten wir böse und gut
auseinanderhalten und eben nicht den
Konsum über den wir jetzt gerade
gesprochen haben so kriminalisieren ich
kenne junge Leute auch als nicht
Richterin die haben ihre
Ausbildungsstelle verloren weil sie
zweimal hintereinander mit Cannabis am
Wochenende erwischt worden das ist eine
Tragödie und das finde ich das reibt
mich auf weil das kann nicht das kann
nicht sein und wir müssen handeln wir
sollten handeln aber eben aus diesen
krassen Fehlern aus diesem was sie
gerade so schön sagten diese Folklore
der Coffeeshops das ist ja wirklich 70er
Jahre Blume im Haar und
weiß ich nicht ist scheußlicher orangene
Lackstiefel anzuhaben
die 70er Jahre und ich glaube wenn wir
offen und ehrlich damit um und deswegen
sage ich auch was ich anfangs gesagt
habe ich habe großen Respekt vor Angst
dass Menschen davor Angst haben es wird
unsere Aufgabe sein politisch
journalistisch medizinisch diese
Diskussion juristisch diese Diskussion
zu führen den Leuten die Angst zu nehmen
und in Deutschland diesbezüglich mal zu
unterscheiden von was reden wir
eigentlich das ist mein Wunsch und dafür
werden wir auch politisch den Eltern die
Angst nehme
in den letzten 20 30 Jahren ich frage
den kommen Eltern bei mir an und sagen
mein Sohn kifft denn sag ich ja wie oft
kifft er trifft ja regelmäßig geht er
zur Schule ja er geht zur Schule welche
Note hat er entsteht bei 1,3 hat er
Sozialkontakte ja hat ja betrinkt er
sich ab und zu am Wochenende ja manchmal
ganz schön doll und dann frage ich die
Eltern und wo ist das Problem und so
müssen wir mit den Leuten umgehen wir
dürfen nicht sagen jeder der kifft ja
wir haben ja das das böse Wort heute
nicht genannt und da sagt ich und neben
den Eltern auch die Angst dieser
einstiegsdrum Theorie die gibt's nicht
mehr die vertritt kein Wissenschaftler
sie noch mal fragen also wenn man jetzt
sagt wir brauchen dann mehr Jugendschutz
darüber sind sich hier alle einig wir
müssen es wirklich kontrollieren wir
wissen dann genau wie hoch der THC
Gehalt hat ist all dieses
trotzdem noch mal die Frage für für
unseren müssten wir dann letztendlich
uns nicht auch viel ehrlicher machen und
zum Beispiel auch über den Alkoholkonsum
von Kindern reden und einfach sagen
müssen grundsätzlich da unsere
Jugendlichen schützen oder wir sagen sie
das kann man einfach gar nicht
vergleichen Cannabiskonsum und
Alkoholkonsum
ja die in dieser Debatte wird ja diese
Analogisierung zwischen dem Gebrauch von
Alkohol was ja in unsere Gesellschaft
starkes kulturelles Fundament hat immer
mit den Cannabinoiden gezogen also das
ist aus meiner Sicht nicht ganz
glücklich natürlich ist der Alkohol
gebraucht genauso wie der Gebrauch von
keiner bemüden mit riesigen verbunden
nur muss man sagen der alkoholgebrauch
ist eben legal in unserer Gesellschaft
und er hat eine gewisse historische
Tradition es gibt ja es gibt auch
Gewohnheiten die sich eben letztlich
etabliert haben ich will das nicht schön
reden das sozusagen ist es eine viel
größeres gesundheitsbezogenes Problem
durch den Alkohol aus durch den Cannabis
gegeben aber durch den cannabisgebrauch
gegeben aber man darf das eben nicht
sozusagen jetzt über einen Kamm scheren
aber man sollte es auch nicht
verharmlosen weil
Alkohol 70.000 ich kenne keinen
ich glaube wir könnten ja noch eine
Stunde weiter diskutieren und wir werden
natürlich auch im Laufe dieser
koalitionsverhandlung dann sicherlich
auch mal etwas darüber hören was dann
jetzt genau geplant ist von der
Ampelkoalition das wir sind erstmal es
wird erst gegackert wenn das ist
[Gelächter]
dass man die frühlingsrunde für diese
Woche bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]